[Music]
god damn look at this can lie so look at
life you feel right now
Ches Ches Ches Ches holy [ __ ] check B
enjoy the you lost [ __ ] boy ajan pain
for the chest teacher and this guy comes
with a pineapple shirt to teach you a
medal go back to bikini bottom right
here rook d2 and rook takes rook King c3
Queen d3 chuckle stop talking [ __ ] I
moved here if you look at the most
popular games on Twitch right now you'll
find the staples League of Legends csgo
fortnight eSports his biggest titles but
recently a new game has made it to the
top of twitch a game that's pretty much
been played the same way for hundreds of
years
oh my god
[Music]
these days it's hard not to hop on
Twitch and see people playing chess
suddenly everyone's in love with the
game that like I mentioned is more than
a thousand years old
and the guy at the heart of it all is
the american super grandmaster Hikaru
Nakamura why was that laughing I was
laughing at the stupidity who karo is
one of the best chess players out there
he's a five-time US chess champion and
at one point he was ranked second in the
world
he started streaming on Twitch
consistently in 2018 and it didn't take
people long to become entranced by his
skills was the line of time I was C 593
there should be 795 255 CD 594 trying to
win upon d5 d6 cted rook d6 and then he
had rigged up he wants of king of Sixers
94 and King f8 than done my king and my
Roper passive pretty soon thousands of
viewers flocked to his stream to watch
and learn from his genius and his clips
got a ton of traction enough to catch
the eye of one of Twitch's biggest
streamers tonight f2 King up to 54 54
Queen f6 or I can even go King III e5
just like rip d1 went out for checking
to 94 I can take people is Bishop takes
84 then I go Queen c1 and I hit that we
don't have for my kings very safe I'm
also going to be able to piece I'm pave
upon a d6 as well so it should be pretty
good for me you execute see caught the
chess bug and decided to start taking
the game seriously cuz you should go
downwards like this yeah it's terrible
to get this hit settle
a pair president she immediately jumped
to the top of the chess section with his
fans also falling in love with the game
those same fans flooded hikaru stream
wanting to know more about it but also
wanting his thoughts and excuses chess
skills that's called the wooden shielded
so what did she look big no big bang pow
Bing boom what Zach the wooden shielded
it's the woman shielded it's the winner
children see because it makes an X and X
and fans finally got the collaboration
they were waiting for a Hikaru xqc duo
stream the chess grandmaster teaching
the overwatch grandmaster okay now
actually what happens here as I have
checking it in one so I play this rook
takes and this is actually checked me
did you see my bishop protected tonight
and your King can't go anywhere here
yeah I see it and this is this is why
what I'm saying like you want to get
your King out of the center of the board
cuz even though here you had an extra
Queen your King was in the center of the
board and so I was able to attack it
much more easily than if it way over on
one side or the other side of the board
what started out as an interest turn
into a bit of an addiction with xqc
playing tons of chess grinding online
matches the entire time we talk today
like it's like the entire time I had
pieces I could visibly see almost in my
children and the whole time thanks to
her Caro and xqc viewers started
checking out other chests channels
although not everybody in the chess
community was happy with this new influx
of viewers flooding their chats and
spamming emotes there was a tournament
that was played online on a different
different site like this past couple of
weeks and because I've been doing stuff
with xqc of course there a lot of like
xdc fans who came and made these jokes
and and the moderate so that channel
basically started like banning everybody
it's like you can't use X you see this
or that some people like us Grandmaster
been fine gold even accused Hikaru of
chasing Fame by playing chess with
people who might not be that talented at
the game
but who are super popular I mean QVC and
box box negative talent and life nothing
not nothing up here nothing here so
obviously if you're a normal person who
has talent like Magnus Carlsen or VL
Kramnik you know you ignore people with
no talent but the car was like oh that
guy has more money than me and he gets
more viewers so I'm gonna try to get in
on that this drama between chess
elitists versus new players has been
making the rounds online there's been
others but Benjamin's been the most
vocal about his disdain for new people
coming in that aren't good at the game
which i think is super [ __ ] silly and
he constantly says like negative talent
you know xqc getting his [ __ ] name
wrong because he can't even do basic
research and box box you know these guys
have negative talent in life feingold
quickly felt the wrath of the twitch
community and apologized but xqc isn't
the only streamer to catch the chess bug
the car was got a bunch of other people
playing the game as well what what is
your background with chess I guess
that's the first mode start it with oh
so I think in like middle school ish I
like was interested in the game I never
have any chest like tournaments or clubs
at school so I never got into it but I
was interested and then throughout high
school I discovered a god mutters
YouTube channel and I realized that it
is a great YouTube channel to use to
fall asleep to and some were pretty damn
good like voyboy who played chess when
he was younger
while all of this is going on hikaru
continues to explode on Twitch the guy's
averaging over 17,000 viewers and thanks
to his rise on Twitch Hikaru has helped
other chess streamers gain exposure by
featuring them on his own channel I know
that the chess category has kind of
blown up and you know it hasn't been
distributed evenly among streamers and
that always happens depending on the
sides everywhere but I'm gonna try to do
some more chess streamer events to help
promote the other chest rivers as well
so hopefully we can use part of the
donations to support that as well hell
even magnus carlsen the best chess
player in the world joined in on the fun
so somebody asks me what my thought is
on chess elitism it seems to be a fairly
new term all I want to say about
elitism I'm not gonna reply to questions
about Ches elitism from inferior minds
Hakkar was even helped set up at which
rivals chess tournament in collaboration
with chess comm which pits some of the
platform's biggest streamers against
each other like fours inbox box and of
course xqc I can't think the rook you
weirdos alright you guys I do believe he
is going to be playing who knows how
long chess will last at the top of
twitch but for the moment it's beautiful
to see both streamers and viewers
embrace a game and community initially
thought to be so different from
themselves and it's all thanks to her
carve thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]